optimal at this altitude i can run flat
out for a half mile before my hands
start shaking and i also the personal
question now it is soon I'm a cybernetic
organism living tissue over metal
endoskeleton this episode is brought to
you by wealthfront and this is a very
unique sponsor wealthfront is a
massively disruptive in a good way set
it and forget it investing service led
by technologists from places like Apple
and world-famous investors it has
exploded in popularity in the last two
years and they now have more than two
and a half billion dollars under
management in fact some of my very good
friends investors in Silicon Valley have
millions of their own money in wealth
front so the question is why why is it
so popular why is it unique because you
can get services previously reserved for
the ultra wealthy but only pay pennies
on the dollar for them and this is
because they use smarter software
instead of retail locations bloated
sales teams etc and I'll come back to
that in a second I suggest you check out
wealthfront calm forward slash Tim take
the risk assessment quiz which only
takes two to five minutes and they'll
show you for free exactly the portfolio
they put you in and if you just want to
take their advice run with it do it
yourself you can do that or as I would
you can set it and forget it and here's
why the value of wealth front is in the
automation of habits and strategies that
investors should be using on a regular
basis but normally aren't great
investing is a marathon not a sprint and
little things that you may or may not be
familiar with like automatic tax loss
harvesting rebalancing your portfolio
across more than ten asset classes and
dividend reinvestment add up to very
large amounts of money over longer
periods of time wealthfront as I
mentioned since it's using software
instead of retail locations etc can
offer all of this at low costs that were
previously completely impossible right
off the bat you never pay commissions or
account fees for everything they charge
oh point two five percent per year on
assets above the first fifteen thousand
which is managed for free if you use my
link wealthfront calm forward slash Tim
that is less than five dollars a month
to invest a thirty thousand dollar
account for instance
now normally when I have a sponsor on
the show it's because I use them and
recommend them in this case it's a
little different I don't use wealthfront
yet because I'm not allowed to here's
the deal they wanted to sponsor this
podcast but because of SEC regulations
companies that invest your money are not
allowed to use client testimonials so I
couldn't be a user and have them on the
podcast but I've been so impressed by
wealthfront that I've invested a
significant amount of my own money at
least for me in the team and the company
itself so I am an investor and hope to
soon use it as a client now back to the
recommendation as a Tim Ferriss show
listener you'll get $15,000 managed for
free if you decide to open an account
but just start with seeing the portfolio
that they would suggest for you take two
minutes fill out their questionnaire at
wealthfront calm forward slash Tim it's
fast it's free there's no downside that
I can think of this episode is brought
to you by 99designs when your business
needs a logo website business card
thumbnail or any other design I
recommend checking out 99designs I use
them myself I've used them for many
years I use them to create book cover
prototypes for the 4-hour body which
went on to becoming number one York
Times best seller I've also used them
for banner ads illustrations and much
more with 99 designs you get a variety
of original designs from designers
around the world give your feedback and
then pick your favorite your happiness
is guaranteed so check out some of my
competitions and designs and some of
your competitions and designs from
fellow Tim Ferriss shell listeners at 99
designs.com forward slash Tim and right
now you can get a free 99 dollar upgrade
on your first design so check it out 99
designs.com forward slash Tim
low boys and girls munchkins and mug
wise this is tim ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show
and I just realized I don't know if the
plural of mogwai is mog wise maybe a
fictional linguist out there can tell me
what the right answer is the Tim Ferriss
show as you guys know probably maybe is
about deconstructing world-class
performers and in this particular
episode we have a repeat guests that is
Stephen J dubner perhaps best known as
the co-author of the freakonomics book
series and creator of the top-ranked
freakonomics radio podcast which I had
the pleasure to be on once it is
incredibly well produced and he is back
to answer your most burning questions
which I'll get to in a minute and he
also has a new podcast that just came
out that you guys check out tell me
something I don't know is the name it is
a new live event end podcast from both
the New York Times and Stephen Dubner
it's you could think of it as equal
parts gameshow talk show and brain
teasers I actually had a chance to
experiment with this for mass for mass
for mass I'll leave it to you what that
might mean for Matt as a panelist
alongside Malcolm Gladwell in a
prototype version it was an absolute
blast to check it out tell me something
I don't know and in terms of topics he
covers a lot that I've been asked about
and he has far more experience in many
of these areas there are some silly
questions like why do cats weevil their
butts before they pounce a lot of you
submitted some pretty ridiculous but
nonetheless pretty funny questions so he
covers a few of those and then jumps
into podcasting and radio journalism
questions about storytelling editing
increasing the reach of your podcast and
then delves into a lot of personal and
book related questions so the destiny as
it were of the Gulf book that he was
working on with his frequent
collaborator and Levitt the three books
that shaped him into the person he is
today so the three books that most
shaped him and if you want to check that
out if you only have five minutes i
would say jump to that
it's 26 minutes roughly after the end of
this intro and does he think he could
take Malcolm Gladwell in a fist fight
that's then a segue to economics so
South Korea and digital currency
cryptocurrency what influence does the
president actually have in the economy
that's a separate question technologies
related to or that actually are part of
VR for instance and how that might
affect education than life advice
teaching kids critical thinking projects
that you might pursue or give to your
kids to get them excited about economics
etc etc it is very very rich and you can
say hi to him at freakonomics on Twitter
Facebook and everywhere else so without
further ado please enjoy this round two
with Steven J dubner hey everybody this
is stephen dubner thanks for sending in
questions to tim ferriss and thanks
especially to tim for letting me take
over part of the podcast today I really
appreciate it i'm a big fan of tim's as
you all probably know we've had him on
freakonomics radio we've had him on a
podcast editable for a while called
question of the day with my buddy James
Altucher tim was also a panelist on this
live version of this game show that I
was developing called tell me something
I don't know which I'm happy to say now
has been developed and it's releasing
kind of this week as a as a brand new
podcast so I'm I'm a big admirer of
Tim's and I really appreciate getting a
chance to talk to people like me who
admired the work that Tim does and how
you know I guess there are a lot of
things I like about it but to me that
the main thing is that it's a real
hybrid of empirical and inspirational
which is I think a winning blend so
anyway the way this worked is Tim sent
out a call via his bat signals to
listeners and readers of his to solicit
questions for me and I got the questions
there are a lot of questions I'll
probably only be able to answer a
relatively small share of them the
questions range all over topics from
economic
which I can talk about a little bit even
though I'm not an economist my buddy
Steve Levitt is the economist part of
our freakonomics partnership but I've
learned a little bit over the years a
lot of questions about freakonomics
radio our podcast about the freakonomics
books all kinds of questions so i will
talk about all that and much more
including like i said this new podcast
that we're launching right now tell me
something I don't know the questions
range from rather substantial to a less
substantial for instance Alex Norton
wanted to know why do cats wiggle their
butts before they pounce so Alex Alex
let me google that for you why do cats
wiggle the butts before that we'll go
their butts before they bounce it is way
for them to get into position and brace
themselves before they attack domestic
cats share a similar feature instead of
grinding the ground with their hind legs
they wiggle their behind vigorously to
attain balance and leverage kittens
learn to do this from their mother cat
so Alex by the way you all know do you
all know the site let me google that for
you because if you don't you should and
it will save you a lot of time in the
end here's a question from Marty boys
'ok maybe so this is a one of several
questions about podcasting essentially
in radio journalism so i don't know how
many people really care about podcasting
and radio journalism obviously anyone
listening to this cares about it as a
consumer I don't know but about as a
producer on the other hand there are
something like between three and three
hundred and fifty thousand podcasts
being published right now so maybe we're
at peak podcast or in podcast bubble I
don't know maybe they'll keep growing I
do think that the consumption is growing
more slowly than the production but
assuming that you know judging from the
number of questions that you guys had
about podcasting I guess that people do
care so I'll answer a few along these
lines Marty wrote to say it seems like
dub nurs unique ability to tell a great
story I like it flattery is what really
adds a viral component to the deep
science and typically boring economic
research how could that story fication
of help other hard sciences or
traditionally boring subjects that are
really important
alright so Marty here's what I would say
first of all thanks for the kind words
it's nice I agree that storytelling is
incredibly important there are many ways
to argue for why that is true I'll give
one example one example would be what is
the best red book in the history of the
world arguably not even really that
arguably most people would most people
would argue that it's the Bible so what
is the Bible well it's a lot of things
but it contains the most famous set of
laws in the history of humankind right
the Ten Commandments so you would think
that everybody would know those since
it's the most famous laws in the most
famous in the most read book and yet if
you ask people it turns out that i
believe it's about seventeen percent of
americans can actually name the ten
commandments and a relatively large
share can't name even one of the ten
commandments so lest you think that this
is just a product of people having a bad
memory i should say that you know
seventeen percent can recite all ten
commandments a higher percent kenrick
and recite either all the ingredients of
a big mac or all six siblings in the
Brady Bunch so that's pretty weird that
the most famous set of laws in the
history of humankind in the most read
book of all time aren't that well known
or at least that well remembered so what
does that indicate i would argue this is
just me making this argument i would
argue it indicates that we meaning
humans really love stories and gravitate
to stories because what we do remember
from the Bible even people who are not
religious at all even people who have no
connection to judeo-christian biblical
traditions at all the stories from the
Bible continue to be passed down and
continue to be known and discussed and
you know maybe not argued about some
people argue about them in a either
academic or you know the theological way
or sometimes even a political way but
people
no who Moses was people know about Adam
and Eve you know once you get into
Christian theology people certainly know
about Jesus and the stories about Jesus
despite even if they haven't read the
Bible at all and so to me that is a an
argument for that and and we can make a
whole lot of other arguments about you
know Gilgamesh and the Odyssey and on
and on and on and Shakespeare and you
know all the way up to you know maybe
even including Pauly Shore for God's
sake so I think that is a piece of
evidence that argues that storytelling
has a power that goes well beyond what
you can kind of you know it goes well
beyond the sum of its parts we actually
did a podcast recently called I believe
it's called this is your brain on
podcasts a freakonomics radio episode
that looked at an amazing neuroscientist
named Jack gallant looked at how
people's brains in an fMRI a functional
magnetic resonance imaging machine
respond when listening to stories told
in a podcast use the moth story our moth
radio hour so it turns out that the
brain you know the the the process the
the production of language is fairly
happens in a relatively small part of
the brain or small area of the brain but
the consumption of language and
especially if storytelling kind of goes
all the way across the brain and so
there is a lot of argument for why
storytelling is really important okay so
if that's the case you know what do you
do about it that how do you harness that
for whatever your goal is so you know
Marty's question seems to be how can
this help other hard sciences or
traditionally boring subjects that are
really important so yeah I think
storytelling can be a big help whether
the the realm that you want to teach
about it or communicate about is physics
is accounting is whatever so I think the
storytelling has components that are
important factual is important empirical
is important you know the thing about a
lot of the academic research so
freakonomics radio we really even though
it's sort of based or rooted in
economics
the fact is is that we try to go way
beyond economics and deal with a lot of
the other social sciences psychology
sociology and so on but also especially
in the last couple years a lot of other
disciplines academic and otherwise and I
think that's important for a lot of
reasons a it's fun to kind of explore
those and teach those and be if you
think about it a lot of the best
research it's being done in the world is
being done in academic institutions but
the nature of academia being what it is
it's kind of a little silo where the the
experts speak to each other they write
for each other in a language of their
own for journals that only they read and
to me that's a shame and a drag and a
waste of taxpayer and other money and so
I'm all for taking that specialized
research and knowledge and disseminating
it to the public to we who want it do we
who could use it and do we who kind of
deserve it because you know we really do
own a part of these universities even
private universities get done taxpayer
funding so I'm all in favor of taking
that big well of material and turning it
into stories again not when I say
stories I don't mean made up I mean
factual empirical research fact-checked
and so on and that's what we try to do
you know pretty much every week with
freakonomics radio i should say this new
show tell me something I don't know goes
even further beyond economics than
freakonomics radio so we're we are
getting ready to release the first six
episodes the first one coming out
november seventh i believe then we'll do
one a week for six weeks and then we're
we're already taping a season two and
will probably release another ten
roughly March or April something like
that and we plan to do 30 a year and and
what's fun about these is even though
this show doesn't feel much like for
economics it's it's alive we tape it in
front of a live audience it's a game
show where contestants from the audience
get up and try to tell us some
interesting fact or story about whatever
whatever the theme of the night is then
I and the panelists discuss it but like
the themes we did for the first six I'll
read them off it was one the first
there's one was called
range danger so it's literally about
things that are dangerous that you might
not think about or know about number two
is called it's alive so it's about
literally anything in the animal ish
Kingdom episode three I believe is
called things that go in your mouth so
food but could be medicine a variety of
other things episode number four of
course things that come out of your
mouth language singing maybe vomit you
never know another episode called
passion plays about people who are
passionate often beyond you know logic
to some cause or hobby or whatever and
our 6 episode is called fool me once
which is essentially about fakes and
frauds of different kinds so in each
case we kind of recruited contestants
often their academics honestly a lot of
them were PhDs or MDS and they tell us
their stories in fact and often the root
of their knowledge is academic even
fairly arcane but in story form these
academic or even arcane stories or facts
in story form they really do enlighten
you so you kind of come away with this
feeling that wow I learned something
that I never would have gone into some
medical journal or economics journal or
you know legal review Law Review Journal
I never would have gone looking looking
for that but when it's told in the right
way by the right people in story form
the idea is that it makes us all a
little bit smarter yeah sure smarter is
good but also you know my argument is
that the more we know the the more kind
of you know I don't know if moderate is
the right word but the more that people
know about the way the world really
works the less stupidity we are likely
to engage it I'm not saying we will
engage in less stupidity but we become
less likely to now there's not a lot of
evidence that huge amount of exposure to
knowledge and information necessarily
makes the average person less stupid and
in fact there's a lot of research that
shows that the most educated people tend
to hold the most extreme views on a lot
of important hot-button issues but I'm a
believer in finding out as much stuff as
I
and and telling other people about it
because it's exciting to share that
that's basically what I do as a as a
journalist whether in writing for more
radio form or whatnot here's another
question about podcasts from stan is
'less eyes lyst sorry i'm gonna i'm sure
mispronounced names by the way he's
asking about tips for editing podcast
one tip is in a podcast you always try
to find out how to pronounce things even
you know when you're writing something
you don't have to know how to pronounce
but often a very basic rule of
podcasting is when you're pronouncing a
place or a thing or a name you do try to
go do some reporting with a first-person
a primary source to figure out how you
actually say it since that's important
you always make mistakes but it's a good
thing to try to do so Stan wants to know
top tips of course I'm ignoring that
advice now I could have hunted down Stan
isla's iceless and written to him and
said how do you pronounce your name and
I didn't so you know sorry anyway Stan I
will call them top tips to edit your
podcast to make them shorter without
losing too much valuable information he
says you cannot beat for economics when
it comes to quality info to length ratio
well it's interesting you write that cuz
I've been thinking a lot about whether
our podcast freakonomics radio
especially is too long and with the new
show tell me something I don't know
again we thought a lot about what's the
optimal length and on that one it looks
like our first six episodes they're all
going to be in the neighborhood of 45 to
50 minutes so the problem is we don't
have really good data on what people
really want not that I would make that
the primary driver of what we do because
i think that when you're creating
something you have to primarily listen
to yourself and your circle of people
that you think are good and smart if
you'd pay too much attention to a big
sloppy feedback loop you'll get
paralyzed or you'll try to please
everybody but in terms of editing so
first of all I do like editing my
podcasts probably do sound you know the
way they do in part because I'm a writer
and came to this came to this as a
writer not a talker and as a writer
editing is hugely hugely important so
whether it's a book or an article or
even an email you know the first version
is never the best there are elements of
it the
are good hopefully but editing is really
important and so my feeling on whether
it's freakonomics radio or tell me
something I don't know or even you know
question the day with James Altucher or
any podcast you as the producer or even
though you're giving it to people for
free right you're not charging them
anything for it you are charging them
for in that you're asking for their time
there's also advertising which say they
might listen to and they might and
that's how most podcasts make money but
you know if I'm asking you for 45
minutes that's a lot that you're giving
me and so I feel it's important just to
work as hard as I can to make the 45
minutes worthwhile so top tips to
editing to make them shorter without
losing too much it's just like writing
every single sentence every single story
every single sound effect whatever you
really just think you know is this
advancing the story is it telling us
something we don't know yet is it not
redundant does it move me does it
interest me as a listener and you know
they're there a variety of intellectual
ways to assess those questions then
there's also the gut check which is when
i listen to a rough cut of any episode
you know do i find myself do I find my
attention drifting and if I do it's a
pretty sure case that's a pretty sure
sign that it needs to be shorter so yeah
I'm pretty ruthless I would say for
every 30 minutes of freakonomics radio
that we put out as a finished podcasters
probably at least typically at least
three to five hours of tape that doesn't
make the cut so that's the idea one more
question about podcasting this is from
rob moore pretty sure i'm pronouncing
that right rob s what are your
suggestions for growing the reach of
your podcast so i think this is really
simple i think if you want to grow the
reach of your podcast you produce good
and consistent content period so
obviously that sounds like a smartass
answer it's not meant to and by good and
consistent that means a few things good
meaning you think about it you produce
it well you edit it well you publish it
well all that stuff consistent meaning
if you're going to be a monthly be a
monthly if you're going to be weekly be
a weekly if you're going to be a day
le be a daily but to put one out on
tuesday and then another one out six
months from now then for in a hurry and
so on that's tricky but i really do feel
that almost everything else that people
talk about for growing something like a
podcast or a newsletter or a TV show
whatever it is i think that almost
everything else that most people
especially in marketing and advertising
realms talk about almost everything else
is overrated so I think that promoting
your work on social media is hugely
overrated I think that marketing is
hugely overrated it's hard to
manufacture demand if however you make
good and consistent content then social
media can help and marketing can help
people will be enthusiastic about
finding and consuming and even promoting
for you what you're making but it's all
about making good inconsistent content
and you should try to spend ninety five
percent your time doing that and maybe
five percent of the time worrying about
growing the reach of your podcast now
that said look I'm doing this podcast on
10 I asked him if I could come be on his
podcast to talk about this new show of
mine and to talk about whatever else
because I've made a show the new show
tell me something I don't know not
freakonomics radio that you know we've
worked hard on for gosh I mean I've been
developing the show for like five years
and I care about it a lot I like it a
lot and and now what I'm doing right now
is not necessarily making that content
any better this is mostly about trying
to expose people to it so this is my
five percent but even in doing that I
wanted to go to places that I thought
were really really really really good
and worth it and to me Tim and tins
audience is really really really really
worth it because you guys have the kind
of you know brains and ambitions and
curiosities and sense of you know what's
interesting and what's not with what's
worthwhile and what's not what's funny
and what's not that I like so there you
go this is part of my five percent all
right here's a new section of questions
that are mostly I guess these are mostly
personal ish and stuff
so someone can't really tell this
person's real name is it's got a lot of
letters typed fast so Lauren maybe
Lorant maybe LaRon dub maybe he asked me
do I know the origin of my last name so
yes I do so dubner was more typically
pronounced Dube nur Dube nurs were my
family came from not originally but in
most recent history from a city in
what's now Ukraine called Dube know and
my family is Jewish the Jews of Dube
know and many other cities in that area
were pushed out of that area when the
new Tsar came in and I think 1881 my
family and a lot of other people from
Dube know ended up getting pushed up
into what is what is now Poland north of
Warsaw a place called Paul tsk and so
most of this also coincided with a time
when many not only Jews but many people
were now acquiring second names because
you know for much of history it wasn't
like we had a first name and last name
the way we do now and so many people
many of the Jews who came from dube know
became Dube nur so Shep soul gubler was
my grandfather for instance Shep soul is
a derivative of a Yiddish for if you
were born on the Sabbath right so
Shabbat or Sabbath or shabbos all these
words that mean in different you know
tongues languages bort Sabbath Shep soul
was it was just kind of a tradition that
part of the world at that time if you
were a male born on that day that was a
name so Shep cyl Dube nur basically
meant a guy whose family had been living
in do blow and then this guy was born on
the Sabbath and then he was the one in
my family on my father's side at least
that came to America and that's where my
name comes from and I know more than I
should about this because my first book
was actually a an exploration of my
family my family has a strange kind of
wonderful weird history and that both my
parents so Shep CIL's son was my father
and my and then my mother both of them
were kind of standard-issue
brooklyn-born Jews who first generate
you know first-generation Americans who
before they met each
they're both converted from Judaism to
Catholicism which is was a very strange
and unusual thing they met they married
they had eight kids on the last of eight
I grew up very very very Catholic but
then very long story short in my 20s I
moved to New York got curious about my
parents Jewish roots and I ended up
returning gradually slowly to Judaism
although I'm not very religious or
observant but it means the traditions
mean a lot to me and so that's why I
know my last name I wrote about all this
in my first book which was originally
called turbulent Souls and then got
re-titled years later as choosing my
religion so that's that raymond waka
waka which i'm going to assume is not a
real name it could be rights to say
what's happening with the gulf book that
you guys are writing and or are there
any new books on the horizon so Raymond
the Gulf book that Steve Lev and I were
working on for a few years just didn't
work out the way we wanted it to we were
hoping to write a book that used
essentially analytics and smart thinking
to help the average golfer become quite
a bit better without actually getting a
little bit better because here's the
problem a lot of people love golf not
many of them are very good and the ones
who are not very good would love to be
better but because of the nature of the
game because it's time consuming because
it's expensive and because it's
difficult most people don't really want
to spend a lot of time practicing and if
you have five hours a week to spend on
golf most people want to get out and
play and not go practice you know
chipping for two hours putting for an
hour and a half and long game for maybe
45 minutes and then you know play four
holes which would probably make you a
lot better over time but most people
don't want to do that and so we tried to
do a series of experiments and analytics
that would help write a kind of Bible
for how to make the standard golfer a
lot better like I said through strategy
through managing the game through
decision-making and so on and you know
you know not going for it not going for
the green in certain circumstances you
know putting from off the green all
kinds of specific strategic ideas and
basically we face
elled we couldn't make people better so
Levitt is a pretty good golf or really
good golfer his handicap I don't know
what his handicap is maybe you're on I
don't know what it is four or five six
maybe in there I'm much less good
Leavitt played as a kid that's my excuse
I didn't play I took it up seriously
only about five years ago and I've
gotten a lot better but the reason I've
gotten a lot better just cuz I practice
a lot take lessons work on it and it's
not like I've gotten a lot better I'm
about now a 12 handicap so that puts me
kind of firmly in the middle of quote
real golfers so not very good but I love
it so yeah that book that book is not
going to happen at least anytime soon we
are however working on a new book whose
completion is not guaranteed we're not
sure if it's going to work out at all if
it does it'll be a couple years and
because of the nature of book writing
I'm not going to talk about it all but
we are trying to do another one a
question from V todas Alec wants to know
what are the three books that shaped me
and why so okay in all honesty I'll say
the first one was a novel called The
Tree Grows in Brooklyn which is kind of
a sappy novel about Brooklyn in the
depression that happened to be hanging
around the house when I was a kid and I
read it over and over and over in part
because I felt it was describing to me
what my parents life was like when they
were kids and as I mentioned earlier my
parents had this weird conversion story
from Judaism big phallus ISM that they
didn't talk about very much and again I
was the youngest of eight so by the time
I was a kid this was ancient history and
so I would read this book kind of as a
secret code to what their lives were
like in Brooklyn and what their
environment was like and it was like
having some kind of access to their
lives that in retrospect it wasn't very
much like what their their actual lives
were like but to me I was an incredibly
formative book and so it shaped me
another one that shaped me a lot was um
a book I remember I remember where and
when I bought it it was on a remainder
table in a Barnes & Noble that was on
Broadway and 7d fourth Street I think i
think it was in maybe seventy-third
Street he was in um yeah it's long gone
anyway it was a biography by Jonathan
Yardley the very good literary critic
who's at the Washington Post for many
years of Ring Lardner who was a writer
Ring Lardner was a writer I liked a lot
if you don't know his work you could
look it up it's very dated now but I
still think amazing he was a sports
writer I love sports writing I love
sports I played sports I loved loved
loved sports as a kid but this biography
of Ring Lardner I'd never read a
biography of an author that was so warts
and all I mean a lot of things that he
did were not so great he wasn't terrible
guy at all but he was whatever he was
kind of selfish and grumpy and and so on
but also it was really about what it's
like to make a life as a writer and I
just moved to New York by up till this
point I was I'd been a musician so in
college so my big things in life when I
was a kid were always sports and music
and writing and I I would like to become
a professional athlete but that didn't
happen I don't know even if I'd been in
the better circumstance I don't know if
it would it happened I was pretty good
but probably in retrospect not nearly
good enough but music was a big thing
for me and I always played music and in
college I got involved in this band
called the right profile and we were
terrible for a long time but then we got
better and better ended up getting a
record deal after a few years moved to
New York and I remember buying the
Jonathan Yardley bio of Ring Lardner
during that time and i was living in new
york with the band starting to make our
first record I ended up quitting music
kind of dramatically because I realized
that was not the life that I wanted was
to be a rock star even though it would
have been fun and it was fun at a very
minor level but I wanted a somewhat more
stable and more anonymous life and I'd
always been a writer I love the idea of
writing i love the solitude i love the
thinking and I loved ring lardner and so
reading this biography of Ring Lardner
was to me again kind of the way a little
bit the way A Tree Grows in Brooklyn was
a almost a Bible for like a blueprint
for like this is what the life looks
like and what I loved about it was
it didn't make it out to be all amazing
and I needed that shot of reality I knew
that writing for living was going to be
very very hard work and that if I wanted
to make it happen they were going to it
was a process we're going to be a series
of steps that you had to you know get
past or succeed at and there'd be a lot
of failure and so that was that book was
hugely formative I don't even remember
the name of the book i think was called
ring so that was book number two that
was incredibly influential book number
three that shaped me I mean if I'm being
honest it's freakonomics that was a huge
deal for me you know the success of it
and the collaboration was lleva those
were big but also just it was a project
that as a writer has launched what for
me is you know we're it was 2003 that I
first wrote about Steve Levy and I wrote
about him because I was in the middle of
a book that was kind of about economics
and so I was asked if I wanted to go
right about this economist Steve Levitan
this award and I turned down the
assignment several times because I knew
levites work a little bit and I knew it
had nothing to do with the book that I
was writing about the book was about
kind of behavioral economics by
behavioral finance what I called the
psychology of money which by the way is
how I met my friend James Altucher he
was a subject in that in that book that
I was writing at the time and so
freakonomics you know I wrote about
Leavitt I found his work so interesting
I loved writing about that kind of stuff
and that led to this collaboration where
we do books together then we do other
things kind of on our own Levitt does a
bunch of stuff on his own consulting and
academic research i do you know the
podcast levites on there but that's
mostly my thing so freakonomics has been
gigantic and the and the collaboration
with levis been gigantic and the amount
of learning that I've been able to do as
a writer and as a radio guy using
freakonomics as a platform has been huge
I mean every day basically my day is to
wake up and try to read or talk read
something interesting talk to
interesting people ask questions find
out stuff figure out how things work
measure it against an empirical standard
then tell the world about it and I love
it I'll tell you one other thing that
kind of inspired me and shaped the way
that I run my like visit my life my work
life was Tavis Smiley so I really like
Tavis Smiley as a broadcaster eat as
radio it as TV he's written books I
found him to be a really good human but
what I discovered when I went out to
California a couple times in a couple
book tours to do his shows I think you
do radio shows and his TV show he had
this kind of complex and he had a
production company and he just had this
whole production setup and the way it
was set up made me realize that man if
you want to do your best work you should
really control or set up as much of your
production as you can because that is
what gives you the latitude and the
leverage to do your best work so that's
inspired me Tavis I've never even told
him this and I probably should because
it was really helpful but the way that
he you know it's a it's a pain in the
neck to set up your own production
company and to do a lot of the
structural work yourself it's a lot
easier to just have someone you know a
book publisher a newspaper radio station
a record label a company of some kind
it's a lot easier for them to say hey
we'll give you the opportunity to do X
and we'll give you why dollars for and
you plug yourself in there that's a lot
easier right and setting up your whole
own thing but obviously if you're
listening to the tim ferriss show you
have at least a little bit of an
entrepreneurial inclination so you know
that the advantages to
entrepreneurialism are huge and the
headaches are huge but watching the way
Tavis operated inspired me to take on
some of those headaches and set up for
instance recently my own production
company to do tell me something I don't
know but also my production company I
certainly we certainly contribute a lot
to freakonomics radio and everything
else and the reason is that look I mean
I've worked with all the institutions I
just named record label newspapers TV
stations radio stations book publishers
on and on I've
worked with all of them in partnership
and they all try to exploit your work
and your content that's their job I
don't use exploit pejoratively that's
their job but I think that in order for
you to do things the way you most want
to do them you have to gain or keep as
much leverage as you can that doesn't
mean you don't share the leverage but i
think it's hugely important to
understand that if you want to do your
best work whether it's media whether its
technology whether its manufacturing
whatever obviously you need partners i
always try to be the best partner I can
I always try to make a deal and make
content that that makes everyone better
off everyone in the partnership but I
find that for me at least the best way
to do that is to have the center of
leverage or the the center of gravity be
in my court so I can say you know I
don't think this should be a daily show
or whatever because I think if we try to
do that I can see why that might appeal
to you the partner is more profitable
ultimately but the content is going to
suffer there's no way that this project
whatever project we're talking about is
scalable enough for it to be good on a
daily level and in order to have the
right to make those kind of decisions
you have to work hard to create the
structure on your own to have the
leverage on your own to have that power
question from daniel rodek rotich maybe
how did you meet James Altucher what
what do you think makes James a good
interviewer and has that contrasts with
your own style so I met James when I was
writing this book that I mentioned a
little while ago about the psychology of
money and James I met him he was the
friend of a friend and i I just I mean I
love and admire James I think he's an
amazing human and very unusual and he'd
made a ton of money and lost all of it
and then some by the time I met him so
it was very I mean bittersweet doesn't
start to describe it fortunately he's
made made a lot back and lost it and
made it so he's pretty good at that so
he said he's been a good friend for many
years I ended up putting that book in a
drawer unfortunately to write
freakonomics but one thing that came out
of it was a friendship with James in
terms of James's style
not only interviewing like on his
podcast but talking to people generally
he just follows his curiosity purely and
doesn't really think about or care at
all about you know looking smart or cool
or whatever he just really really really
wants to know what he wants to know and
I find that to be an incredibly
attractive trait especially if you're
doing journalism and interviewing Steve
Levitt my freakonomics co-author is very
similar in his research and it takes us
it takes a certain amount of I guess
courage to really not care what people
think about you and I wish I had more of
that I work on it but I think James has
that in spades question from Lance
Miller do you think you could take
Malcolm Gladwell in a fist fight so I
don't think I've ever actually been in a
fist fight but um I think I could take
Malcolm only cuz I mean he's wiry but I
got a few inches in a few pounds on him
I think I could take him on on the other
hand I think he could just outrun me so
I'm um I'm fairly fast like I can sprint
I can do that you know I've played
sports where you sprint and I'm but I
was always a relatively fast but
Malcolm's a distance guy he still runs
like it he still runs semi competitively
mile and more so um I think it wouldn't
get to a fistfight plus neither of us I
think you know you have to take your
glasses off it's a lot to worry about
there but thanks for the question Lance
ok here are a few questions about you
know economics ish stuff from John none
John writes to say South Korea announced
that they will be developing a digital
currency what are your views on digital
/ cryptocurrency and how will this
development affect the dynamic of these
currencies in Asia hmm i don't know
about the second half how will they
affect the dynamic of the currencies in
asia we actually did a freakonomics
radio episode a few weeks ago called why
are we still using cash and i personally
believe that the data argue that the
more digital we get with money
the better off more people will be so
within that you have to say well there
are some people who are going to be
frustrated that cash is used less there
are people who worry about privacy there
are people who worry about government
intrusion there are people who worry
about the flexibility and liquidity of
cash or people who worry about
technology of having digital money and
what happens if it all goes you know if
there's the biggest black out in the
world and these are all legitimate
concerns that need to be addressed in
are being addressed by places that are
converting to cashless or less cash
society I think the but i think the
advantages to having much less cash
especially big bills is huge so one
thing we discussed in the episode of
freakonomics radio is that I believe
it's eighty percent of u.s. currency now
in circulation is in hundred-dollar
bills very few people use hundred-dollar
bills in the normal course of
transaction fact it's not very easy if
you give a taxi driver 100 if you could
go into a grocery store give 100 people
don't even really want them so we're all
these hundreds are used by people who
are buying and selling drugs involved in
other illicit activities often
corruption bribery of different kinds
and so it turns out that eliminating and
maybe on a gradual basis rolling down
the ladder the big bills would probably
do a lot more good than bad another
thing is you know in the US people have
a weird relationship with the government
look we just do and I get it I get both
sides or all sides but I think that some
of the arguments when you hold them up
to light or kind of silly so you know
people who come a lot of people who
complain about taxation I feel are
complaining about the wrong side of
Taxation if you're honest you want good
enforcement good payment because the
larger the tax gap is the tax gap is a
difference between what's owed and
what's paid the Lord root is the more
the honest people are penalized so to me
it would seem a no-brainer for everybody
that's honest which is most people to
close the tax gap and one way to close
the tax gap is to make it a lot harder
to cheat and one of the easiest ways to
cheat is due
business in cash just the way it is so
that's another reason for going to less
cash Peter Connelly wants to know what
actual influence does the president have
on the economy so Peter I love this
question I love it well okay
narcissistically I love it because I've
been asking this question a lot for
several years so it is a subject of
great debate I dealt with this at some
length in an episode of freakonomics
radio called how much does the president
really matter and the argument there
from talking to economists and some
legal and constitutional scholars and
some political scientists was not very
much especially when it comes to the
economy because if you think about it
the economy is you know it's big complex
dynamic system with all these inputs and
it's influenced by all these factors
many of which are psychological not even
just purely financial and a lot of them
would seem to be largely immune to any
president's wishes on the other hand and
we recently did another freakonomics
radio episode called has the US
presidency become a dictatorship and in
some ways this episode was a rebuttal to
my own argument in that earlier episode
and in this episode I talked to the
legal scholar Eric Posner who I find to
be really brilliant and really
insightful and a great communicator you
should read his stuff I read this was
based on an essay he'd written for
Daedalus but if you google Eric Posner
he's also happens to be the son of
richard posner who's a prolific and very
well-regarded intellect a judge but also
writes a lot about economics and other
things so the Posner family is worth
your time reading so the legal scholar
Eric Posner argues that due to a long
and interesting history of the US
presidency and how its evolved a lot
over time and how its veered a lot away
from what was conceived as the original
Madisonian system of checks and balances
that the presidency has attained much
more unilateral power and therefore
especially through executive decisions
and legislation that the president now
often make policy not necessarily
unilaterally but often close to it as I
reach over huge swathes of the economy
so take just two specifics health care
and financial services so health care is
moving toward twenty percent of GDP I
think financial services I don't know
the number but obviously it's huge if
you look at just those two you could say
well the president him or herself can't
really do so so so much to shape the
economy in those realms but through you
know through through legislation
necessarily or at least we'd like to
think that that power has been
constrained but if you look at the
reality you see that just during the
Obama administration and this is really
what the episode of freakonomics radio
with Eric Posner deals with Allah is a
you know using executive order to make
decisions and to push them so neither
Obamacare nor the financial regulations
and financial legislation that came out
of the recession neither of them were
achieved primarily through executive
order but they've been furthered and
advanced and kind of enforced in that
way and so anyway you look at it the
president has the ability to exert a lot
more leverage than the founders
certainly intended partly because the
Constitution is vague on this but the
point that Posner makes it's really
interesting to me is the president gets
this power has gotten this power over
the years and is constrained we like to
think that the presidency is constrained
by Congress in the Constitution but
Posner's argument is that Congress and
the Constitution don't constrain the
president very much at all the
Constitution almost none and Congress
for all that Democratic Congress will
compete for all that a Democratic
president will complain about Republican
Congress being you know recalcitrant not
letting him get anywhere and vice versa
it turns out that Obama did a lot that a
Republican Congress did not want him to
do in Posner's argument is that the main
constraints on a president is that
he or she represents three different
constituencies the public the the the
the you know the the country generally
the party and the executive branch so
the president is the putative leader of
those three things he's a leader of the
country he or she is the leader of the
the political party his or her political
party and he's he or she is the leader
of the executive branch and and here's
the way Posner puts it trying to be the
leader of these three different groups
with different interests and values
turns out to be an extremely difficult
task so that is what creates the larger
constraint constraints over the
president that said I've been making
this argument for a while that the
presidency you know we put way too much
you know we think we put way too much
care and anxiety and into thinking about
the choice of president is so essential
to everything that influences our daily
lives and I still think that's true i
think that the actual presidency doesn't
affect us individually very very much
but i have come around to the idea that
the president in ways that are kind of
non-obvious exerts a lot of influence
over huge pieces of the economy that
certainly does trickle down max
McFarlane wants to know how will
technology such as VR impact education
and will students being taught through
online and digital medium how a mite
their intelligence be affected by
teaching more through online and digital
media that's a really i like that
question a lot so my thoughts on
education are I guess voluminous for no
good reason I than that it interests me
a lot we say we care about education a
lot I don't think we do and when I say
me I mean kind of you know the body
politic we care about our own kids a lot
but I don't think we really care about
education a lot i think if we did we
would do a lot of things in the
education system that are really really
really different we'd have it be more
accountable we'd have it be more
experimental we'd have it be more
empirical and we'd have it be well yeah
let me go back to experimental so in
answer to Max's question about about VR
virtual reality specifically I have no
idea I'm I don't predict the future
because
is bad at it as everybody else but I do
think there are things going on in
education in education theory and in
technology particularly that are really
interesting so there's a there's a
startup it's now called new classrooms
it started out called school of one and
it was a pilot project within the New
York City Department of Education run by
a guy named Joel rose and Joel rose then
took it private I guess private now it's
called new classrooms and their model
this is just one one small example that
I'm impressed with their model is to go
into let's say a fifth grade math
classroom and you know what's the
standard model of Education a teacher
and 20 or 30 kids in a room and some
kind of chalkboard whether its digital
or otherwise and you know it's often
been said that if you went to sleep
about 120 hundred fifty years ago and
woke up today you would recognize very
little about America or the rest of the
world we transportations different
communications different on and on but
you'd recognize the school classroom
it's basically the same as it was then a
bunch of kids teacher running things
right and there's been some innovation
and some use of technology and you know
best practices but honestly compared to
other industries and I know it makes
people nervous talk about education as
an industry but boy if you look at the
funding it certainly is and it's an
important one because the ROI is massive
if you look at it as an industry you see
that the amount of innovation has been
really really low so school of one for
instance would say you know we're going
to take this classroom full of 30 kids
and instead of assuming that the best
way to teach all 30 is to have all of
them listen within the same amount of at
the exact same time to the same teacher
telling them the same thing well maybe
that's not optimal what would happen if
instead we created several different
modes for each of those kids to learn
and engage in so maybe yeah maybe the
teacher is leading a group maybe it's a
small group lesson for kids who happen
to learn well that way maybe some kids
are learning one-on-one with a virtual
tutor maybe some kids are in a pure let
group maybe some kids are using virtual
reality maybe some kids are doing drills
on their own and school of one basic
we are now called new classrooms
basically takes this model and every day
you experiment with every kid learning
the same material through different
modes to see which mode that kid happens
to learn best in and then you have a
test at the end of the day that's how
you know what mode works for each kid
and then the next day your algorithm
spits out playlist for the following day
to give each kid their own customized
way of learning it's very dependent on
technology in a good way i would argue
it would make the role of the teacher i
would argue even more important although
i think a lot of teachers fear that
would make them less important and it
does what to me the whole almost every
other facet of life is done which is try
to customize things you know to work
better for you know none of us want to
walk into a store whether it's virtual
or real virtual or brick and mortar and
have a choice of one thing you know
here's a clothing store here's the coat
we have today here's the shirt we have
today here's the book for sale today
here's the podcast to listen to we all
want choice it's not just about
preference it's about how we learn and
people are really different and so I
think that the more we can use
technology and also just logic and data
to customize to some degree the
educational process the better off we'll
be I think I've been talking for a
really long time I'm gonna try to find
one more question here that would be a
good one to end on we've been talking a
little bit about education alright so
I'll combine a couple here's Christina
Anna Shiva Shiva and Jill Bevan craddock
have questions christina s I'd love to
know how to best teach kids to have
critical thinking and ask unusual
questions so I love that question
Christina and Jill wants to know what's
a great project for seventh graders to
get excited about economics so combining
these
too I will say first off I'll start by
saying I have no idea how to what's a
great what's a great project for seventh
graders to get excited about economics
and I would kind of go back to my
previous previous answer which is that
you know customization is really
important and so to that end I'm a
really big believer in letting people
whether it's adults whether it's in your
work career whether it's people in there
obviously in their consumer choices but
even in education I'm a big believer in
letting people find the topics that
they're fascinated by almost addicted to
then urge them to channel that
fascination into learning a lot of
different things using that topic or
using that fascination so one thing that
strikes me is weird about school the way
we still do school is we require every
kid to be involved for many years in
every subject art fizzy and fit math and
English and history and obviously you
want to have everybody have a certain
core base but almost nobody's good at
all these things and and the and the
result of being in almost inevitably
really bad at one or two it's just that
make you kind of hate the process or
make many people hate the process
especially boys you see the boys don't
do very well in primary education often
because there's there's just too much
funneling and channeling your interest
and your attention into things that are
not interesting or that don't hold your
attention and then of course we blame
them which i think is crazy so I do
think it's great if you can like I said
let people or lead people to find a
topic or a curiosity that is legit it's
organic for them and then use that to
learn a lot about the rest of the world
and i think you know if you're a good
teacher if you're a good parent or just
a good you know adult a thoughtful
person you can find a way to learn about
so many different elements so many
different disciplines within one thing
so i'll give an example my son who's now
16 he doesn't like school very much he
does pretty well in some subjects not so
Ellen others it just it's just not a
great fit I don't think he's ever going
to be a great school student on some
dimensions he's really really smart and
on some dimensions he's really really
interested and so I do try to encourage
him so his be
obsession for the past like five six
years has been football soccer what we
in America call soccer which he calls
football because he's kind of a snob
that way so like you know he really
really he reads a lot most of the books
he reads for fun or about football most
of the you know journalism that he reads
I mean he keeps up with politics and
stuff more than I think pretty pretty
well for a sixteen-year-old kid he does
it a lot through comedy by the way you
know Jimmy Fallon Jimmy Kimmel Colbert
those are that's the way he gets a lot
of his news which i think is not a
terrible way to get your news because I
don't know funny news about the new I
don't know if comedy about the news is
actually any funnier than a lot of the
real coverage about the news personally
so I'm personally pretty good with that
but then with with football or soccer
like also he and I do it's gotten more
occasional lately it was more regular
for a while a podcast about him
basically teaching me about footy called
footy 42 and the amount that you can
learn about the world through something
like football about economics and
politics and language and society
generally and how the media operates so
if you follow football closely as he
does I mean you can learn all of this
and it's about as global as it gets so
that's what I would say to Christina and
Jill and anyone who's looking for you
know kind of ways to quote teach kids to
have critical thinking ask unusual
questions or what's a great project to
get seventh graders excited about
something is you know the excitement um
try to find an organic excitement and
then develop that and let it go as deep
and wide as you can for me as a kid the
channels the topics that I learned about
the world through were sports which led
to just you know you learn a lot about
different things personality stuff
political stuff on and on music I love
but back then especially there was less
kind of real good information about but
to me the hobby that I did which is you
know super nerdy whatever but I love was
stamp collecting it's like when I was a
kid collecting stamps I did it I didn't
do it as a learning exercise I did it
first
whatever reason I thought it was really
fun to collect different pieces of
colored paper from around the world I
just thought it was fun I like the
organizing principle i like the hunting
him down but the amount that i learned
about i learned way more about the world
through stamp collecting than I ever
learned through geography or even world
history I learned about economics I
learned about royalty I learned about
political upheaval I learned about art
all this stuff through this thing that I
happen to love so I think that look the
fact that you were listening to the tim
ferriss show indicates to me that you
are a person who is deeply passionate
about something beyond like having fun
and getting pleasure out of life and
don't get me wrong I think having fun
and getting pleasure out of life are
hugely important and they're really what
drive us at the end of a day but I think
the fact that you're listening for this
also indicates that you have a real
burning passion for something either
vocational or career wise or creative or
artistic and I think the more honest you
can be about you know do the thing the
more honest you can be about doing what
you love because you love it and then
try to harness and leverage that love
you know it's really hard to work hard
on something you don't love and that
you're not passionate about I think a
lot of us especially early in our
careers we try to fake it try to
persuade us as all yeah I really want to
go into you know Investment Banking
because I think it's really interesting
to get in there and learn about how
companies work and da da da then you see
a lot of people in fields like that
where they go into them early you find
that really what they wanted was they
wanted to make a lot of money which is
fine money is hugely important but you
find that the passion doesn't match your
your energy and so I think if you can
align your passion and energy you will
work so hard and do so well that you'll
you'll become successful without even
really noticing you're becoming
successful because you're just doing it
you're just doing your thing so Tim
thanks for having me Tim Ferriss show
listeners thanks for having me I do hope
you'll
keep up with the work I do can follow
freakonomics stuff at freakonomics
Twitter and Facebook the new show that
I'm really excited about if you couldn't
tell is called tell me something I don't
know hoping to get Tim back on it as a
panelist soon and I guess that's all I
have to say it's been a real pleasure
and a privilege and i love the questions
and i very much appreciate the
opportunity to come talk to all of you
cheers hey guys this is tim again just a
few more things before you take off
number one this is five bullet friday do
you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
for me every Friday that provides a
little morsel of fun before the weekend
and five bullet Friday is a very short
email where I share the coolest things
I've found or that I've been pondering
over the week that could include
favorite new albums that I've discovered
it could include gizmos and gadgets and
all sorts of weird [ __ ] that have
somehow dug up in the the world of the
esoteric as I do it could include
favorite articles that i have read and
that I've shared with my close friends
for instance and it's very short it's
just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend so
if you want to receive that check it out
just go to four hour work week dot com
that's four hour work week com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you will get the very next one and
if you sign up I hope you enjoyed this
episode is brought to you by 99designs
when your business is a logo website
business card thumbnail or any other
design I recommend checking out
99designs I use them myself I've used
them for many years I use them to create
book cover prototypes for the 4-hour
body which went on to becoming number
one York Times bestseller have also used
them for banner ads illustrations and
much more with 99 designs you get a
variety of original designs from
designers around the world give your
feedback and then pick your favorite
your happiness is guaranteed so check
out some of my competitions and designs
and some of your competitions and
designs from fellow Tim Ferriss show
listeners at 99 designs.com forward
slash Tim
and right now you can get a free $99
upgrade on your first design so check it
out 99 designs.com forward slash tip
this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront and this is a very unique
sponsor wealthfront is a massively
disruptive in a good way set it and
forget it investing service led by
technologists for places like Apple and
world-famous investors it has exploded
in popularity in the last two years and
they now have more than two and a half
billion dollars under management in fact
some of my very good friends investors
in Silicon Valley have millions of their
own money in wealth front so the
question is why why is it so popular why
is it unique because you can get
services previously reserved for the
ultra wealthy but only pay pennies on
the dollar for them and this is because
they use smarter software instead of
retail locations bloated sales teams etc
and I'll come back to that in a second I
suggest you check out wealthfront calm
forward slash Tim take the risk
assessment quiz which only takes two to
five minutes and they'll show you for
free exactly the portfolio they put you
in and if you just want to take their
advice run with it do it yourself you
can do that or as I would you can set it
and forget it here's why the value of
wealth front is in the automation of
habits and strategies that investors
should be using on a regular basis but
normally aren't great investing is a
marathon not a sprint and little things
that you may or may not be familiar with
like automatic tax loss harvesting
rebalancing your portfolio across more
than ten asset classes and dividend
reinvestment add up to very large
amounts of money over longer periods of
time wealthfront as I mentioned since
it's using software instead of retail
locations etc can offer all of this at
low costs that were previously
completely impossible right off the bat
you never pay commissions or account
fees for everything they charge Oh point
two five percent per year on assets
above the first fifteen thousand which
is managed for free if you use my link
wealthfront calm forward slash Tim that
is less than five dollars a month to
invest a thirty thousand dollar account
for instance now normally when I have a
sponsor on this show is because I use
them and recommend them in this case
it's a little different I don't use
wealthfront yet because I'm not allowed
to here's the deal they wanted to
sponsor this podcast but because of SEC
regulations come
that invest your money are not allowed
to use client testimonials so I couldn't
be a user and have them on the podcast
but I've been so impressed by
wealthfront that I've invested a
significant amount of my own money at
least for me in the team and the company
itself so I am an investor and hope to
soon use it as a client now back to the
recommendation as a Tim Ferriss show
listener you'll get $15,000 managed for
free if you decide to open an account
but just start with seeing the portfolio
that they would suggest for you take two
minutes fill out their questionnaire at
wealthfront calm forward slash Tim it's
fast it's free there's no downside that
I can think of
you
you